now to a big story developing overseas
the former soviet state of belarus
is ruled by a man described as europe's
last dictator
but now widespread protests are trying
to force him
out of power after he claimed 80 percent
support
in last week's presidential election
it's raising concerns
that russia may try and take control
chris livesay
is in minsk belarus's capital
unprecedented outrage over an election
demonstrators say
was stolen by the president they're
demanding
step down over my dead body says
alexander lukashenko
and forcing his opponent to flee the
country lukashenko's refusal to step
down has set the stage for a showdown
with protesters who say
they have nothing left to lose
protesters savagely beaten by police the
crisis has sparked concerns from the
white house
it doesn't seem like it's too much
democracy
there in belarus and widespread fears
russian president vladimir putin
will prop up his former soviet ally
meanwhile belarus is conducting military
drills along its border with nato member
lithuania to counter alleged
foreign threats as the people of belarus
plead for one thing
we want clear and honest
after 26 years of rule europe's
so-called
last dictator has lost his country
for cbs this morning chris lipsey minsk